bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue en
ce vendredi dans sa hotte caddie avec
notre invité ce matin adam squatter
bonjour bonjour bertrand bonjour amusé
auditrices et auditeurs de la première
voilà une voix bien connue en martinique
adam squatter journaliste et président
du club presse de martinique et en tant
que président du club presse adam
squatter un regard mais aussi en tant
que journalistes et citoyens
un regard sur l'état des lieux on plante
le décor après quasiment me presque un
an maintenant et en mars après un an de
crises sanitaires et autres parfaitement
il se trouve que l'état des lieux c'est
quoi ce que légèrement avant la pandémie
avant le mois de mars
une étude avait été faite par un
organisme qui s'appelait six ans sur un
tout petit peu sonder les journalistes
l'échantillon n'est pas important mais
assez représentatif 355 journalistes
pour leur demander l'état des lieux de
ce qu'ils sont alors c'est la notion
d'engagement d'engagement dans la
profession qui vient en premier
je pense que s'il ya une notion à
retenir sur ce qui s'est passé ces douze
derniers mois
c'est franchement la notion d'engagement
l'engagement à la fois sur le terrain
pour faire ressortir justement une
information sur vérifier et v non non
contestable est à la fois accompagnés
également les scientifiques ou les
décideurs dans dans ce qu'ils font dans
la crise
2 2 deux à kobe de la comique et se
trouve effectivement c'est un temps de
crise que la demande d'information
augmentaient très sensiblement ceux
connus d'un stade de l'humanité on ne
pas rassurer on va aller ailleurs pour
en savoir plus justement pour comment se
comporter comment cette définir un temps
quatre personnes avec avec un contexte
particulier quand même dans le monde que
l'on vit aujourd'hui 2020 2021
c'est évidemment l'ampleur qu'a pris
donc compris les réseaux sociaux
les et voilà et donc c'est vrai que les
journalistes professionnels
j'entends alors n'était peut-être pas au
premier front c'est vrai que c'était les
personnels soignants évidemment les
pouvoirs publics les élus etc qui devait
prendre des décisions mais néanmoins les
journalistes d'après ce que vous dites
étaient au coeur finalement de la crise
et est l'interface entre les uns et les
autres je savais que j'aurais parfois
les difficultés je serai à deux fois
validée là le travail du scientifique
beaucoup de choses ont été validés cette
année si on y regarde de très près par
les médias havas même pas les organismes
scientifiques ou halo bousculé le monde
des scientifiques qui était dans son
cocon de confort bien sûr ce sera un peu
les bousculer et mais l'autre chantiers
sur lesquels journalistes professionnels
je me to you ça maintenant un peu et on
pourrait même le m'étendre il ya messi
c'est d'être en confrontation ou en
concurrence plus exactement avec les
réseaux sociaux et là je pense que s'il
ya une donnée aussi essentiel à retenir
2020 2021 et ce n'est pas encore terminé
c'est justement cette confrontation ça a
été jusqu'à maintenant une sorte de mise
à l'épreuve si on le veut bon on regarde
ce qui s'est fait en robes on dit alors
là aujourd'hui c'est réellement savoie
lionel ce que le temps que consacre le
journaliste professionnel à voir ce qui
se passe sur les réseaux sociaux
je crois que est beaucoup plus important
ce temps-là s'élargit de plus de plus en
plus alors vous savez le temps passe
très vite nous avons dix minutes d'une
interview avec vous madame squatter
président du club presse martinique
alors justement en tant que président du
club presse aussi mais en tant que
journalistes et citoyens
vous aviez pris une position suite alors
on vient ce qui s'est passé récemment en
martinique vous aviez pris position suit
donc à à l'intrusion récente dans les
locaux de deux médias à me semble-t-il
atv et rci
ici donc d'un groupe de personnes de
citoyennes et citoyens qui souhaitaient
exprimer leurs positions leurs idées
leurs thèses à propos de la vaccination
alors vous vous étiez notamment
concernant atv vous étiez à ce moment là
invité dans le journal télévisé vous
étiez dans les studios cc bien sâr
exacte et donc vous avez assisté
vous étiez là j'ai pris position mais
maintenant à froid avec un peu plus de
recul
qu'en dites vous alors ce que j'ai dit
c'est que d'abord toujours l'indignation
est toujours là et je crois que ça a été
un choc compréhensible dans la rédaction
de happy atv au moment du grand journal
que ça se produit alors aujourd'hui à
froid qu'est ce qui est à faire je pense
qu'il ya une mobilisation forcément
faire une mobilisation de la profession
autour de 7,2 cette question parce que
je pense que on a frappé puis à la halle
à la porte des rci balade d'après les
remontées que nous avons eue est
également ici devant le service public
de l'audiovisuel l'a7 oui cette session
a eu un tendre et ça effectivement ça
dans le cadre d'un débat sur notre
antenne de télévision mais ça s'est
relativement bien passé il ya quelques
personnes une dizaine de personnes qui
s'est retrouvé sur l'esplanade devant
l'entrée générale de martine que la
première mais bon voilà il ya pas eu
d'échauffourées il ya rien ne nous dit
que quand il ya crise et inquiétude est
que les désordres parce qu'il s'agit de
ça il faut nommer les choses sinon on va
pas s'en sortir jeu car il ya la ja il
ya une sorte de désordre qui est en
train de s'installer et de prendre les
médias comme cibles et là la vérité si
ils ne méritaient existants c'est quoi
c'est quand on doit pouvoir se dire les
choses en face à ben voila je pense que
j'allais vous dire c'est pts et adam
voter parce que faire dans tous les we
sur tous les médias mais vingtaine et
vous dans cette affaire ce que vous
distinguer la forme et le fond
parce que l'objectif initial non de
vouloir exprimer des positions non
c'est notre rôle aussi de la position
des positions qui sont défendues à
longueur de journée sur martinique 1ère
crc ailleurs il y rencontre je recevais
une invitée qui exprimait justement
c'est le vent de réserve phase actuelle
de notre travail de journaliste dans
notre travail des médiateurs de
médiateur il faudrait toujours avoir un
débat on le dit à qui libre et c'est ça
le dis tout ce que sinon il est marrant
des sangsues éclairant au comédia en
martinique
donc ni dans la forme ni dans nos fonds
je crois que ce genre d'action une
intrusion sur une médias dans un média
pub plutôt n'est acceptable mais par
contre il s'agit de pouvoir donner la
parole à tout le monde dans un cadre
déontologique c'est à dire de faire un
vrai débat contradictoire
tu as fait et ensuite tous les heures
les téléspectateurs telle partie
citoyennes et citoyens se font leur
opinion après et je deviens ces débats
existent oui je ne dirais pas
abondamment mais à l'ong de jeunesse et
les médias y compris le nôtre plus plus
globalement en ce moment on sent bien
qu'il y à aussi justement un débat sur
les conditions de la liberté
d'expression mais vous savez à à l'aune
de ce qui s'est passé par exemple aux
états unis on a vu c'est quand même
ouais c'est édifiant on a vu le compte
alors particulier individuelle du de
donald trump officiellement encore
président des états unis la leur on
parle être suspendu par par exemple un
réseau social enfin un réseau social
voilà et des semaines de tour suivant
l'arrêt rappeler au grand public
c'est quoi ce que ces mêmes c'est ce
même donald trump depuis 2016 à son
arrivée au pouvoir qui a dit une fois
des médias alternatifs donc les médias
dits traditionnels quelque part et qu'on
peut faire c'est news fox news qui a
participé
à son élection sont discrédités sur
cette base là aujourd'hui c'est qu'il se
passe à sa relève du législateur en tout
petit peu de nettoyer est-ce qu on peut
s'en est ce qu on peut mettre fin
justement à la communication avant que
la personne elle même n'a pas respecté
les règles du dih travail d'autant plus
que les états unis comme vous le savez
vous l'avez vu ce sont les médias qui
officiellement annonce la victoire d'un
chef d'état une victoire qui est par la
suite validé au monde dit simplifié par
le sénat alors voilà très bien non même
si c'est sous toutes les latitudes bon
j'ai cité l'exemple des états unis mais
on peut dire aussi par exemple qu'en
chine les conditions de la liberté
d'expression et de la liberté d'informer
la beauté nous mais oui si on prend bien
sûr l'article 24 d'ailleurs qu'il sera
soumis ces jours ci il revient en valais
couture sur l'a6 séparatisme c'est la
sécurité globale
exactement
l'ensemble des dispositifs prête à
confusion un fait prête à discussion
plus tôt mais ce volet de l'article 24
qui sera réécrit et que soumis la
semaine là cette semaine au sénat
je pense que n'est pas il va avancer
pour la démocratie française en termes
d'indépendance faut balayer aussi deux
devant sa porte
y compris en france et y compris aussi
en martinique parce que la presse aussi
peut faire des erreurs parfaitement les
mains terminée si je dois tu es sur
comment s'est passée cette année 2020
cette année particulièrement difficile
enfin assez inédite pour le club presse
et puis quelles sont les perspectives
pour 2021 est ce que va la fête dieu je
veux dire énormément stand by pour
plusieurs raisons à la fois de pouvoir
se rencontrer à la fois de pouvoir se
voir et de décider les projets qui
avaient été retenues notamment de prix
aliker de journalisme destination des
jeunes le centenaire du journal justice
ont été pratiquement pris du retard au
pratiquement sans respirer pouvoir les
tenir son service
on pouvait aller tenir certains
d'autant plus qu'il ya un autre
anniversaire c'est à pal le journal qui
célèbre ses 40 ans un autre journal
d'opinion à côté de justin oui donc se
passe et plus on évite les débuts de 21
ans aussi je pense que nous initierons
une rencontre beaucoup plus globale
entre tous les professionnels du du du
journalisme en un mort technique sans
plus tarder d'ailleurs au rendez vous
est déjà pris merci adam swat et n'avoir
perdu à metz et à nos questions bonne
journée et bon week-end à vous tous vous
retrouvez jimmy damas